another round of Russian missile strikes
has hit the Ukrainian city of zapparija
the Region's Governor says a school was
among the buildings attacked on Tuesday
morning two rockets hit a car dealership
killing one person Moscow has been
shelling the region intensely more than
two dozen people have been killed in the
last week
Ukraine says it will not be intimidated
by the wave of strikes
explosions on Monday killed at least 19
people and injured around a hundred in
several cities across the country the
U.N has joined the U.S and the European
Union in condemning these attacks but
Russia's President says there are more
to come
Rory challenge is in Kiev Rory air raid
warning sounded across Ukraine again
this morning tell us about that
yeah the active air raid warning has
been on for at least three hours now
that's why I'm wearing this body armor
across the whole of Ukraine we
understand that Russian strategic
bombers Chipotle bombers have been up
over the Caspian Sea region and
launching more cruise missiles at
Targets in Ukraine uh the latest that we
know of is that there were at least two
that were intercepted over the Kiev
region in the South uh Odessa mikalayov
it seems like a number of of drones have
been intercepted there too at least one
got through to the central city of
Venezia though and hit a power plant
there and as you were just saying
zapparigia continuing to Bear the brunt
of night after night of strikes from s
300 missiles now these are older and
cruder than the cruise missiles that
have been launched at other parts of
Ukraine they're essentially an air
defense system which has been adapted to
hit ground targets not very accurate but
still damaging enough as we've seen in
the pictures there hitting a car
dealership a school killing one person
it's why uh president zielinski is
stepping up his cause for sophisticated
air defense systems for Ukraine he says
this is an absolute priority
and meanwhile Rory Ukraine is still
taking stock of all the attacks that
took place yesterday
hmm
yeah I mean that yesterday was a step
change really for for the country not
since the beginning of the war has there
been such an onslaught uh so many cruise
missiles and drones launched at Targets
across the whole country so we know now
that 19 people died another 105 were
injured critical and civil
infrastructure targets were you know the
main objects hit uh we know that there
were Targets in 12 regions uh and the
City of Kiev 35 30 fires began all of
those are out now 300 settlements around
the country towns and Villages are still
without power in Kiev itself they are
planning rolling power Cuts around the
city different times scheduled at
different times to try and balance the
power supply for the city because there
were at least three power infrastructure
targets hit in those attacks yesterday
you know the the intent is clear isn't
it from Russia uh with all of these
strikes
the what they are trying to do is to
degrade the civilian critical
infrastructure of the country and with
hits on Town centers City centers to
instill as much fear into the population
as possible Rory challenge reporting
live from Kiev thank you very much
a Ukraine's ambassador to the United
Nations has condemned Moscow for
targeting civilian sites he was speaking
during session of the U.N General
Assembly
today terrorist Russia sell the capital
city of Kiev and many other Ukrainian
cities throughout the country with at
least 84 missiles and two dozen uavs
energy facilities
residential buildings schools and
universities
museums
and Crossroads in the city centers were
among the targets that the Russian
defense Ministry later declared
legitimate
or diplomatic edits of James Bays has
more from the United Nations in New York
Russia was very unhappy with the way
things developed in the general assembly
there were a number of procedural votes
none of which went Russia's way and at
the end of um his time in the general
assembly the Russian Ambassador told me
it was an outrage he said in his time as
Ambassador uh he'd never seen anything
like the way the general assembly
business was conducted by the president
of the general assembly he said it was
wrong and it's not the way business
should be done at the United Nations now
what the Russians had been hoping to do
by procedure is get the vote that we're
going to have at the end of this session
as a secret ballot vote and that's not
the way uh the U.N General Assembly
normally votes normally when a country
votes in the general assembly everyone
gets to see how they vote but Russia was
defeated in that and it didn't like the
way the procedure was handled by the
president of the general assembly what
will happen now is this session will
continue we think it's most likely
because there are lots of speakers that
the vote the final vote which is on
Russia's annexation of Ukrainian
territory will take place on Wednesday
or perhaps even Thursday now the votes
on procedure perhaps give us some idea
of who is on Russia's side and who is
not and certainly it's pretty clear from
those votes I think that when it comes
to the vote on annexation on the actual
subject this is all about then Russia is
not going to win that vote
James Bay's reporting there Ukraine's
air defense systems are set to get more
advanced in a phone call with a
Ukrainian leader U.S President Joe Biden
promised more support shihabra tansi has
no more now from Washington D.C
we've got the readout from the White
House Joe Biden expressing his
condemnation at the attack his
condolences to the loved ones of those
who were killed or injured but then the
readout goes on President Biden pledged
to continue providing Ukraine with the
support needed to defend itself
including Advanced Air Defense systems
now we know already that the Pentagon
says at least two two rather
surface-to-air missile systems will be
in Ukraine by November that's what they
say and another six have been pledged
although those may take years to arrive
because these aren't just off the off
the peg off the shelf they aren't coming
from the US's existing stockpiles they
have to be contracted and built uh more
Western Nations apparently rather
unwilling to give their own service to
Amazon systems to Ukraine they say that
they need them themselves these systems
can attack drones and missiles and
helicopters we understand so that that's
the the air defense system part I don't
know whether this means that you know
there's some we'll hear more about
perhaps a speeding up of the supply then
to go on with the the readout Biden also
underscored his ongoing engagement with
allies and partners to continue imposing
costs on Russia and now this week
there'll be plenty of opportunity for
that we have the virtual G7 meeting on
Tuesday with heads of state uh virtually
meeting and then later on in the week we
have in Brussels the meetings of NATO
and the Ukraine defense contact group
that's a grouping that was set up in
April of almost 50 Nations and we have
the chairman of the joint Chief of Staff
staff and the defense secretary already
on their way to Brussels for that